[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the trial of ex-minnesota police officer
kim potter begins she pulled out her
firearm
she pointed it at his chest
and she shot
and killed dante wright mr wright can
stop
all he has to do is stop and he'd be
with us
we take you inside the courtroom for
opening statements from both sides and
tv star jesse smallett takes the stand
in his disorderly conduct trial what he
revealed in his lengthy testimony plus
convicted wife killer william argy faces
the ultimate sentence there is nothing
that will make this emptiness go away or
erase the pain of knowing the true
anguish that maureen was in before her
life was stolen and later a missouri
woman accused of murder takes the stand
in her own defense i'm being accused of
murdering my husband
did you kill ben i did not law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with the contentious
case of minnesota versus kim potter as
the trial for the ex-police officer
begins on wednesday the jury heard
opening statements from both sides ahead
of emotional witness testimony potter is
charged with first and second degree
manslaughter in the death of 20 year old
dante wright back in april wright was
pulled over in brooklyn center minnesota
for unregistered tags on his vehicle at
the time he called his mother and told
her officers pulled him over for having
an air freshener hanging in his rearview
mirror officers then realized that
warren was out for his arrest body cam
footage shows a struggle between wright
and the officers potter a 26-year
veteran of the force yells that she is
grabbing her taser but instead it
reaches for a gun wright is shot in the
chest and dies shortly after potter
maintained she accidentally grabbed the
gun instead of the taser in its opening
statements the prosecution noted potter
was trained annually for both gun and
taser use she had completed her most
recent training just one month before
wright was killed
and on april 11th of this year
she betrayed a 20-year-old kid
she pulled out her firearm
she pointed it at his chest
and she shot
and killed dante wright
now the defendant was a 26-year veteran
of the brooklyn center police force
for 26 years
she went out on the streets with the
obligation to serve and protect and
you'll hear she was trained not to use
unnecessary force
she was trained not to shoot an unarmed
driver
she was trained not to fire into a
vehicle
and she was also trained not to use her
taser on a fleeing suspect
and she was trained to be aware
of the differences between her gun
and her taser
and importantly she was also trained
about the risks of pulling the wrong
weapon and that drawing and firing the
wrong weapon
could kill someone
the defense followed with his opening
statement arguing kim potter is human
and made a mistake they also said dante
wright would still be alive if he had
cooperated
mr wright can stop
all he has to do is stop and he'd be
with us
but he goes
she can't let him leave
because he's going to kill her partner
and so she does taser taser taser and
she pulls the trigger
believing that it was a taser
or why else would she say it
and immediately
upon pulling the trigger a single time
which is the training for tasers
the train for gun is to pull twice
she realizes what has happened
much to her
everlasting and unending
regret
she made a mistake
this was an accident
she's a human being
joining us today is legal analyst su-ann
robinson and terry austin so when the
prosecution led with a strong opening
but also raised the question of whether
or not potter should have even used a
taser what do you think of the opening
i think the opening did a great job of
laying out the fact that police officers
have a higher duty in terms of safety
and in terms of following the rules and
so when kim potter is going against all
of her training all of her experience
when the state starts to bring that out
it will lay perfectly into the argument
that this is not a simple mistake this
is something a decision that kim potter
made that she should be held accountable
for based on her having a higher duty
based on her training and experience as
a police officer
terry the defense animated and banging
on the podium at times focused more on
this being a mistake was it persuasive
especially after the prosecution's
opening
it was not persuasive i think banging on
the table was overkill and i think
starting out your opening statement
saying that the victim is responsible is
offensive if only he had listened to
what the officer was saying if i'm on
that jury i'm thinking to myself no if
only kim potter had not pulled out her
gun instead of her taser so i don't like
his argument he also tried to say that
this was an action error meaning that
it's the same as if in january you write
the wrong year because you are
accustomed to writing the old year i'm
sorry when you kill somebody it's not an
action era it is a huge devastating
mistake and it's manslaughter you either
were culpably negligent or you were
reckless yeah it's interesting writing
the wrong gear in january as opposed to
having 26 years of training and make a
mistake
i don't know it's apples and oranges but
we'll see how this continues as more and
more testimony is presented to the jury
now to get to the gi lane maxwell
federal trial out of new york the
brother of a maxwell accuser does not
take the stand after speaking with his
sister about her testimony the man known
by the pseudonym brian was removed from
wednesday's witness list after speaking
with a witness known as jane one of
maxwell's accusers several other
witnesses did take the stand including
jeffrey epstein's chief pilot david
rogers and sean the boyfriend of another
one of maxwell's accusers carolyn shawn
testified that carolyn was 14 years old
when she worked for epstein 59 year old
max will face his federal sex
trafficking charges for allegedly
helping epstein groom teenage girls for
sexual abuse epstein maxwell's longtime
companion was found dead by suicide
after he was charged for seminal crimes
still ahead on law and crime daily just
one day after the jury reaches a verdict
william rg is sentenced for the murder
of his wife
but first closing the arguments begin in
the trial of tv actor jesse smallett
what the actors said while on the stand
after this
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back in chicago closing
arguments begin in actor jesse
smallett's disorderly conduct trial this
after the defendant takes the stand the
former empire star is accused of lying
to police after he reported two masked
men physically and verbally attacked him
near his home in 2019. prosecutors
alleged smallette hired two brothers to
jump him and leave him with minor
injuries for publicity somali denies the
attack was a hoax the actor took the
stand on monday and tuesday calling the
brothers liars he testified that he met
the alleged attackers on the set of
empire he also told jurors he had a
sexual relationship with one brother
that included going to strip clubs and
doing drugs together last week the
brothers testified neither of them had a
relationship with smallett but that they
were hired to stage the attack if
convicted smallet faces up to three
years in prison
let's bring back legal analysts suanne
robinson and terry austin to discuss
jesse smallett on the stand terry it
seems like a difficulty of this case for
the defense because they actually have
to prove a case not just pork holes in
the defenses does millet do that here
well i mean the prosecution still has
the burden of proof i mean select
certainly has to tell his side of the
story and you know he's been charged
with six counts of disorderly conduct
for filing these false reports but the
prosecution i think has really
demonstrated that smollette lied about
being attacked i mean the testimony of
the ostendario brothers was excellent
and i think that
uh jesse was not able to show
that he
you know was attacked and and i think
that that is going to go to his
credibility there's no question about it
that the ocean dario brothers were
better witnesses than he was yeah it's
interesting it's one of those cases of
he said he said he said i guess and it
appears that credibility leans more
towards the prosecution than the defense
so man the prosecution didn't call any
rebuttal witnesses after smallett
testified what does that tell you about
how the prosecution thinks their case is
going
i think the prosecution thinks their
case is going okay the little string
that i got from jesse smallett's
testimony is the the sexual relationship
he had with ola and the fact that ola
testified and completely denied that he
had a relationship after kind of the
premise of the entire their side that
they were hired is that they have a
relationship they're just denying allah
is denying the sexual relationship to me
and if i was on jury i would say wait a
minute is that a motive
for ola and this brother to attack jesse
smallett to want to attack his
credibility to want to
you know cause harm to him if they
indeed were in a relationship and trying
to keep it secret and you know um jesse
smallett wanted to say something or
there was some issues i think the fact
that they're directly conflicted head to
head on whether or not they had this
relationship and jesse smallett is so
clear as to the details of the
relationship and they're completely
denying it gives a little string of
motive as to why the brothers would be
attacking jessie smallette if they're
trying to keep that relationship or that
interaction a secret swan the way you
put it makes sense to me let's see if
the defense uh can put that together in
their closing arguments because as you
always say it takes just one juror to
have that thought and maybe that's uh
jesse smelled saving grace in this case
we'll see as this case continues coming
up on law and crime daily hear the
firsthand testimony of a missouri woman
on trial for the murder of her famed
snake breeder husband plus emotional
victim impact statements as new
hampshire man william r g is handed down
a hefty sentence all that and more after
the break
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily just
one day after a guilty verdict is handed
down william bill argey is sentenced to
life in prison without parole
after less than three hours of
deliberation a new hampshire jury found
argy guilty of first-degree murder and
falsification of evidence prosecutors
say argy strangled or suffocated his
wife maureen before attempting suicide
throwing out her cell phone and going to
a casino at the time of his wife's
murder argy was in a gambling addict in
debt who had just lost his job he also
was a sole beneficiary of his wife's 400
thousand dollar life insurance policy at
our allergy's sentencing hearing on
tuesday maureen's brother gave an
emotional victim impact statement
there is nothing that will make this
emptiness go away or
erase the pain of knowing the true
anguish that maureen was in before her
life was stolen
i hope you as the defendant as you leave
here to spend your remaining years
in your hell that you deserve
you also know that someday your children
will know the truth about what you did
to their mother you will no longer
receive calls from your children or
letters from your children
you will never see them on christmas
morning and see the utter joy and
delight in their eyes
instead you have stolen their innocence
they will not ask about you or talk
about you
and you will become a distant memory
you are a selfish cowardly pathetic
person
who deserves to die alone
miserable and locked away for the rest
of your life
legal analysts suen robinson and co-host
terry austin joining us again to break
down this verdict and sentence terry
after the verdict was read we all knew
the sentence so why do you think we
still do victim impact statements if
they won't change the sentence
that's a very good question brian but
the purpose of the victim impact
statement is to give the family and
friends an opportunity to discuss what
the loss is to them in their own words
and in this case we heard from the
mother we heard from the brother we
heard from the sister-in-law and to tell
you the truth that was the most
impactful statement to me she talked
about the little things like the recipe
for apple crisp and it just makes you
feel how much of a loss this is to
everyone in that family not to mention
the two children so it gives them a
little bit of closure and an opportunity
to say what the loss is absolutely at
the time of catharsis for those victims
or those people affected by the death of
a loved one so man what was your
reaction to the victim impact statements
when you first heard them
i think that it's a part of the circle
of justice right after the conviction is
in the sentencing is in for the families
to do that i think the victim impact
statements also give you a peek into the
person who you refer to the entire trial
as the decedent as the victim and
sometimes by their name obviously you
get a peek into who they were you get
that spark of life and you get to really
understand like terry was saying and
like you were saying who they were and
and what the loss really means to the
people who cared the most about them
yeah justice accountability closure
that's what the criminal court system at
least attempts to try to strive to in
terms of finding some end in these cases
uh thank you both for your input when we
come back lindley renee takes the stand
in her own defense as she stands trial
for the murder of her husband up next we
take you into the missouri courtroom to
hear the testimony firsthand
welcome back a missouri woman takes a
stand in her own defense as she's
accused of murdering her famed snake
breeder husband
thirty one-year-old renig testified on
wednesday she is charged with
first-degree murder and armed criminal
action after her husband 29 year old
benjamin renick was found shot and
killed at his reptile shop back in 2017.
prosecutors say lindley rennick hatched
a plan to kill her husband with her
ex-boyfriend michael humphrey and
co-worker ashley shaw they say she owned
a spa that was losing money and was the
sole beneficiary of her husband's one
million dollar life insurance policy
years later lindley renning's other
ex-boyfriend brandon blackwell came
forward to the police with information
about the murder while on the stand
renik testified about her multiple
affairs relationship up and downs with
her husband and about the lies she and
ashley told
what should you have told them
everything
i
i should have told him about
wanting to go to the facility to talk to
ben and
how michael had pulled out a gun and
shot him and
everything that ashley and i you know
lied about afterwards about
everything
why didn't you
i mean at that point
i had lied so many times
and it was just
admitting i mean
i myself was trying to just run
from the truth
of what had happened and having to sit
there and
face officers and tell them the truth
tell them about all of the times that i
lied and really have to
to face myself and what type of person
that made me
to lie about
all of those things and cover up my own
husband's murder
ahead of her testimony co-defendant and
ex-lover michael humphrey took the stand
as a witness for the prosecution
humphrey testified that he was there
when renick shot her husband
i was looking at a
whole lot of snakes
and
then i heard a shot come out
which
inside there was extremely loud so i
kind of ducked a little bit i looked
down through there
and she was at the end of the
corridor whatever you want to call it
posed up like this with a gun would it
be fair to say you heard several more
after that initial shot right but you
you turned and ran out the door correct
where did you go
to my car
um
not immediately i pulled the door open
and i'm looking back up there to kind of
see what's going on it was a few seconds
she comes out the door i'm still
standing there she runs around the
[Music]
passenger side of the car
and
starts screaming at me to drive
basically
the jury also heard from ashley shaw
redding's co-worker who prosecutors say
conspired with her to kill benjamin
renick
lynley rennick walks up to you and out
of the clear blue sky
asks you
ashley shaw the not violent person who's
afraid of dateline to commit
the most serious crime there is
and you say yes that's your testimony
yes sir
and
your reason for this
i think you testified a second ago
is
i
don't
no
correct
in addition to feeling bad yes oh
feeling bad
so when you feel bad for somebody
you're gonna help them murder somebody
does it sound reasonable
that somebody like you would really do
this
i wish that i could
say that it didn't but i did so
it does to me
if there were ever a pair of star
witnesses in a case it would be humphrey
and shaw so let's break down their
testimony suanne was shaw a credible
witness to you
absolutely this is you know her girl
bestie at work her co-worker that she's
confiding in about all the problems in
her relationship that there's abuse in
her relationship and she's and she also
works at the facility and is basically
trying to help her run the business and
knows that the business is in trouble so
she has a dog in the fight it might be a
puppy but if the spa goes down then
obviously she's gonna lose her job and
her best friend is telling her that her
husband is terrible he's doing all these
terrible things so she's there thinking
all right i'll help you do whatever you
need to do to get out of this situation
so that sounds like a like a long
sentence under i don't know i'm trying
to help my friend because i wanna out
she's told me that she's not in a safe
or or comforting environment with with
her husband yeah and it sounds like a
motive not just for her friend but also
for her personally in terms of her work
and and where she gonna pick up a
paycheck terry how damaging was
humphrey's testimony against renick or
do you think the defense succeeded in
their cross-examination
oh i think that humphrey's testimony was
extremely damaging of course you know
he's in jail so his credibility is at
issue here but he has absolutely no
reason to lie no matter what he's still
going to prison for life for
second-degree murder the small charge
related to the weapon was dropped that
makes no difference at all whatsoever
and i think the defense basically did
not do a good job they were talking
about lies and of course you're gonna
lie after an event like that all right
we'll see how this case continues as we
continue to watch it thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you